Hello and welcome the fire of learning
Britain from a small island nation to the
largest empire the world has ever seen
an empire upon which the sun did not set
and in technicality still does nuts set.
How was this achieved?
What was the secret to Britain's
success in empire building?
Well,
to begin,
one of the first big reasons for Britain
success was geography from the start of
the nation.
England was protected from the conflicts
and interests of the continent by being
surrounded on all sides by
water. Well, almost all sides.
You may remember Edward Longshanks
ranting about not controlling the whole of
his island in the movie Braveheart and
his frustration was completely justified
if the island where unified it would
provide an important strategic advantage
for England getting whales
and especially Scotland,
who was historically an enemy of England
and worst and ally of the arch nemesis,
France off their backs.
This was essentially achieved in 1603
when King James became the monarch of
England, Scotland and Ireland and
England started to become Britain.
Giving it a complete shield of
sea water is a nice advantage.
It makes it harder for enemies to come
into your territory if they must also
travel by sea,
but C's are not impenetrable and the
English learned that lesson the hard way.
Early on in the early Middle Ages,
the English went up against the power
with a superior navy. The Vikings,
the vikings spread havoc on England
and nearly conquered the Anglo Saxon
kingdoms entirely though
eventually thrown off,
only to be conquered by half
biking group known as the Normans.
The English understood
that to protect our nation,
they would have to invest in a powerful
navy. As the centuries progressed,
that navy saved their country
on multiple occasions,
including during the failed
invasion of the Spanish armada.
During the English Spanish wars and the
battle of Trafalgar and the Napoleonic
wars as Edward Gray would later say,
the British army should be a projectile
to be fired by the British navy.
The stress that the English began placing
on our navy in the late Middle Ages
and renaissance came at the ideal time.
The perspective that Europeans had of
the world was expanding as the Americas,
Africa and Asia were being explored and
the way to get to these places was by
sea. The English had the scramble, the
Ketchup to the Portuguese and Spanish,
but when they did,
they were active participants of rising
trade exploration and colonialism.
Britain was now on the playing field
to dominate the world though rivaled by
other powers like France, Spain,
Portugal, the Netherlands,
and Russia on these new confidence for
centuries to the Europeans advantage,
the natives of these regions were
less technologically advanced,
lacked unification, and were susceptible
to things like diseases. However,
it would be a struggle for Britain
to become top dog in the world.
Empire game in the 18th century though,
controlling much of the Americas, Spain,
and Portugal is power began to decline.
The Netherlands were knocked out of the
game significantly in the 17th century
along with Scandinavia.
Russia expansion was not fueled by a
strong navy and was therefore a focused
mostly on lands which
were connected to its own.
Austria was too burdened by mainland
conflict and Italy and Germany lacked true
unification until the 19th century.
This left France as Britain's
main enemy in the 18th century.
Britain and France fought it out over
the course of the 18th century and a
series of almost constant
war than conflicts.
One of the most important conflicts of
this era and in world history being a
seven years' war in America and Canada,
the seven years' war as often downplayed
as merely the French and Indian war,
the war between Britain and
the French and a native allies.
But it was much more than that.
It involved all major
European powers at the time.
It was fought on all continents
except Oceania and Antarctica.
And in many ways it was the first real
world war and the site of the future of
North America and South Asia.
When Britain secured his presence and
influence of her friends and he's regions
following the French and Indian war.
However,
Britain took a major setback in the late
18th century when it lost some of its
most important colonies,
the 13 in North America,
which became the United States
after throwing off British rule,
an event which was encouraged and
received an important assistance from
Britain's arch nemesis, France.
Though this was crippling,
Britain bounced back that century as it
retained other important colonies like
Canada and expanded into Australia,
India, and other parts of Asia.
All while France struggled to
recoup the for France could recover.
Though it underwent a
decade long revolution,
which spilled over into other parts of
Europe and threatened not only British
possessions like Ireland,
but also the British government itself.
When the revolution ended,
it did so under the rule of Napoleon
who said about conquering the whole
continent and had a specific
interest in Britain.
Though Napoleon's invasion
of Britain failed. As I said,
France remained a critical threat on
which Britain focused its resources and
tried to rally the continent
against for over a decade.
While in the poem was having great
success on the main continent,
he did fail with Francis,
former colonial possessions.
He reclaimed Louisiana only to sell it
to the United States and lost Haiti to a
slave uprising for the more he failed
to challenge Britain and other parts of
the world leaving the path the colonizing
these places open to Britain when
Napoleon was eventually to feed it,
it paid off greatly for
Britain as it entered into
what is called Pax Britannica,
a period of relative
peace among Europeans.
In 1812 the empire struck back against
the U s and the war of 1812 though this
ended in a stalemate following this war,
Britain made a tactically wise decision
and pursued neutrality and eventually
friendship with the United States allowing
Canada to be essentially unbothered
by American power, which would
begin to grow in the 19th century,
but pose no threat to other
parts of the British empire.
This is not as say that Britain had
an open road to the world empire.
It was becoming France.
Though setback was still in the game.
Germany was on the horizon and would
be a major competitor to Britain.
Britain also had to compete with Russia
and the Middle East and Far East,
and what is known as the great game.
Japan and China proved to be industrious
and powerful nations, et Cetera,
but by the 19th century,
the British empire,
his position as world power was
established. It ruled Canada, New Zealand,
Australia,
and India relatively safely.
The crumbling Ottoman Empire allowed
a route to expand into the fragmented
Middle East and the Conquest of Africa
was shared in an organized by many
European powers.
The first great threat to the British
Empire came in the 20th century with World
War One which did in fact
wound Britain greatly,
but ultimately led to the expansion of
its empire achieving its apex and 1920
not even a century ago,
and controlling one quarter of the
entire planet's land mass and population.
To summarize Britain's
geographical advantage,
it's rule over the whole of its island.
It's emphasis on having the
most powerful navy in the world.
It's investment in trade and exploration.
It's dry if to colonize the world.
It's victories in wars against contenders,
such as in the seven years war and the
avoidance of issues that other mainland
nations face, such as men and conflicts
allowed it this serious advantage. Also,
keep in mind that science and technology
were embraced in Britain early on.
For example, the industrial
revolution began in England.
Britain's power fell after
the Second World War,
which damages Europe and cause massive
decolonization and independence movements
across the world,
which led to the official end of the
empire in 1997 but its influence on the
world remains on matched and its legacy
on beaten. For more videos like this,
I'd invite you to check out my channel,
specifically the history playlists,
and for more videos on many other topics
from vikings to terraforming, to dreams,
to coffee, to a documentary on English
history to aliens, and much more.
I'd invite you to check out the rest of
fire of learning and keep up with them
in the future by subscribing.
Thank you for watching.